guys Tuesday November 4th next week is
election day it is an off year election
it's a midterm election meeting the
president is not being voted for we
can't boot out Obama I know if you want
to do that I know have you want to keep
them around for a third term can do
either one of those things this is for
your congressional people this is for
some governor's things of that nature uh
so what to talk about voting because
people are so polarizing everything they
do and I want there something on my mind
I hate you and yet you know what people
don't vote the voting numbers are just
abysmal I don't have them in front of me
right now but take my word for it or
google it uh the voting people just
don't vote I'm sure this week I
discussed how Eric Garcetti who is the
mayor here in Los Angeles got thirteen
percent of the vote that's right the guy
who is running Los Angeles one of the
biggest cities here in the United States
got thirteen percent of the vote and
then we wonder why things don't work out
well maybe we're not getting the right
people because if people don't vote then
the guys that are running maybe aren't
going to be the best quality and there's
a series of other reasons why we're not
getting good quality people but we'll
save that for another video anyway it is
the most important thing you can do as a
citizen is vote so not just talk about
it but actually learn what these people
want yes our system is seriously broke
the money in politics they're all sell
out nobody has you know beliefs that
they really stick to what we know all
that but if we don't hold them
accountable for that and the only way
you can do it it's not by screaming and
it's not by a hashtag on Twitter as much
as I love Twitter that's not anything
negative about Twitter it's not about
that you gotta get out there and vote
there are things they could do for us to
make us vote we should have uh I'd say
this all the time but uh election day
should be a national holiday that is the
most important thing you can do that is
the best duty that you could do is a
citizen so give us that day so we can
vote but you gotta get out there but
because if you don't then complaining
about it and wondering why these people
don't do the right thing and wondering
why they care more about money than what
you say which is what we all talk about
constantly right well guess what that's
never gonna change but by actually
showing up and saying Here I am I'm
gonna vote this is a democracy this is
what it's all about that
biggest threat to the power and that's
actually what changes things so get out
there tuesday november for